bonjour à vous merci de tracts sur arte
france 9000 cas hier un record depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire faut-il
s'inquiéter réellement a certainement
ses afin de vous inquiéter
je dirais que la catastrophe n'est pas
demain et comme l'a dit tout à fait mon
collègue urgentiste pour l'instant les
hôpitaux sont tout à fait capables
d'absorber de la quantité de la quantité
de malades qui pourraient se présenter
mais c'est simplement le témoin de la
circulation de plus en plus importante
du virus
c'est un petit peu comme une inondation
c'est à dire vous voyez de remonter
avant qu'elle déborde qu'elles dépassent
le haut sommet de la vie dévoile aux
bombes
on sait qu'il va y avoir un problème le
pouce est de savoir quand et là
l'objectif c'est de d'essayer de
ralentir cette montée des eaux pour
préparer tout ce qui est tout ce qui est
nécessaire de préparer on est exactement
dans ce dans ce cas de figure c'est à
dire qu'il ya de plus en plus de
personnes qui sont contaminées pas
forcément drame mais qui sont
susceptibles de transmettre le virus à
des personnes qui elles sont fragiles et
là va commencer le problème avec les
mains avec la capacité d'accueil du
système de santé
moyennant quoi on n'est pas non plus
dans le cas du mois du mois de mars ou
du mois de février où on découvrait la
maladie maintenant c'est beaucoup plus
et donc on s'est beaucoup mieux
comment préparez comment se prépare et
comment préparer les hôpitaux et comment
même se prévenir parce que pour
l'instant il ya énormément de pia dans
la population plus jeune est beaucoup
moins que dans la population plus âgée
eu deux hypothèses c'est que les
personnes les plus âgées ont bien
compris comment il fallait se protéger
alors résister à tout prix un
confinement est ce que la solution c'est
de tester massivement la solution c'est
de tester le plus possible autour des
cas qu du sel pour isoler les gens qui
sont potentiellement contagieux c'est ça
le alors après
et simplement pour avoir un nombre de
tests en soit ça n'a pas l'utilité
particulière
je vais dire tester 50 millions de
personnes qui serait négative n'a aucun
intérêt
le le test il doit être parfaitement
écrit sip totalement accessible pour les
personnes qui sont en contact ou
cliniquement suspecte et au contact d'un
patient qui lui est positif c'est là où
il ya un intérêt parce qu'il ya une
mesure derrière il ya des mesures
d'isolement de 2,14 m aujourd'hui on
teste en priorité les cas je veux dire
les les cas que l'on soupçonne parce
qu'on remarque quand même que c'est
compliqué dans les laboratoires il ya
des délais quand même important et un
embouteillage
il faudrait qu'ils aient cette
priorisation je ne suis pas persuadé
qu'elle est soit effective partout
la preuve d'ailleurs lui et les queues
invraisemblable devant les devants les
laboratoires tous ces gens là ne sont
pas des contacts de cas avérés ce serait
ce serait absolument invraisemblable
donc il ya forcément d'un nombre de
personnes qui ce test par on va dire
convenance pour ce pour se rassurer on
comprend le besoin de se rassurer non
plus sept ans est une fausse réassurance
puisque quand on est négatif à jour on
peut l'être le lendemain on peut devenir
positif le lendemain dont il faudrait se
tester tous les jours pour être
complètement rassuré donc le long
l'utilité du test à très large échelle
c'est de pouvoir dépister et retrouver
les personnes qui doivent être isolées
justement à ce niveau est ce que le
le message des autorités il est
suffisamment clair sur la stratégie à
adopter en matière de dépistage et de
tests en bas les consignes que nous nous
avons dans le corps médical chanson est
ce clair il ya deux ce côté là il n'y a
pas de problème après comment est-ce que
c'est compris en population générale
c'est toujours une distorsion forcément
c'est normal c'est toujours le cas mais
en prennent normalement effectivement il
y à la liste est précisément la liste
des cas de figure où il faut il faut
tester aulas est-ce qu'il faut soutenir
les laboratoires aujourd'hui si oui
comment pour éviter justement une
saturation
il faudrait que moins de personnes haïes
se faire dépister alors qu'il n'y a pas
lieu l'aide de le faire c'est à dire de
cibler encore un peu plus et là c'est un
problème de discipline de chacun d'eux
de ce2 ce2 d'aller dans un laboratoire
quand y en a vraiment besoin c'est
vraiment pas la peine d'aller se faire
dépister juste parce que on est inquiet
tel jour lise rabat je vais me faire
tester
non ça surtout pas c'est parfaitement il
était l'un certains médecins se
plaignent lorsqu'ils reçoivent un
patient avec des symptômes ils disent tu
ne passes pas l'aiguillé parce que les
laboratoires ne répond pas vous
confirmer qu'il ya certains endroits on
pas partout certaines régions faire
cette ville nous placer où ça se passe
bien et puis d'autres où ça se passe
plus mal mais effectivement c'est une
c'est une réalité
et justement parce que il ya
encombrement probablement exagérée des
laboratoires pour l'instant c'est clair
alors qu'elle est le résiduel qui ferait
que
seul si seul fait qu'ils ont besoin de
se faire dépister bon laboratoire qu'est
ce qu'il resterait comme encombrement
pour l'instant je suis bien incapable de
vous le dire mais en tout cas ça ne
réduirait fortement c'est une évidence
merci à vous jean-paul celle d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur de maladies
infectieuses et tropicales au chu à 2
grenoble